[Music]
spectacular
first images here these are coming to us
live this is the fragment
actually entering the lower atmosphere
wait where's explosion what's the chunk
of rock rocks don't explode
okay tell that to the dinosaurs we are
still waiting for the first images
of the actual splashdown that's expected
in the atlantic ocean
earlier footage showed
hmm
the state of florida central florida
with the impacts
epicenter reported just outside tampa
stretching
to orlando and that fragment which
scientists are estimating was the size
of a
football stadium uh has apparently sent
a shockwave
felt as far as 1500 miles
uh i have to warn you there are no words
for what you are about to see
these are disturbing disturbing images
they are coming to us from a local news
helicopter
in tampa as well as overhead
[Music]
wait are some more pieces gonna hit bear
with us here we don't have much more
information
than these images unfortunately we have
lost
contact with our affiliates in that area
the uh the presidential election victory
we're
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
robbins air force base warner robins
georgia
at 9 45 p.m eastern standard
been texted to time please confirm you
are receiving it
by pressing maybe we got the same
message on the tv why did only john's
phone get it
and unfortunately we don't have any more
information than these images
that you're seeing we have lost contact
with hey they said one back each but i
don't even know what i'm talking for hot
cold
i don't know call both i guess you
where's this insulin supply
uh cabinet top left corner remember to
get the cartridges from the fridge this
is gonna be enough for a month
a month a month a year i mean we're
gonna be prepared ally
oh sweetie hey hey look at me
everything's fine we're just rushing
because we really don't want to miss
that plane
okay we're gonna take his trip but we're
all gonna be together
impact tampa is a city of just under
400 000 people you're almost ready to
get a long drive give me the uh
the bag for the insulin the bag the
backpack
where's nathan i thought he was with you
nathan
nathan nathan come on let's go
but the sky's on fire
okay we're good yeah
two days they got it all wrong there's a
[ __ ] ton of fragments on that thing
they're saying that one of them is a
planet killer and now they're grounded
all non-military flights i mean what do
we do
i don't even know if the shelter
relocation thing is is real just
[ __ ] and you know it
i'm sorry okay i'm sorry it's just just
please give us a call
if you find out anything when you get
there look where we can go to be safe
you know i will end
good luck good luck
wait stop
you can take ellie please please we
can't take her dad
you can take allie blaze maybe we should
no ellie we can't take her
dave i'm sorry we can't take her i am
begging you
for christ's sake get out of the way
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
but why what well so we take her to the
air base and then we got standing there
alone when they turn her away
[Music]
seek shelter immediately what do you
think it is
no idea
the only thing people want to talk about
today is this interstellar comet called
clark
nasa's saying it appeared out of nowhere
from like a different solar system
this is the fragment entering the lower
atmosphere three
two one an impact
where's the explosion what's a chunk of
rock rocks don't explode yeah
tell that to the dinosaurs
the sky's on fire come on let's go
with the largest fragment expected to
hit in less than 24 hours
space agencies are expecting an
extinction level event
the greatest chance of survival where
the bunker is in greenland
[Music]
we're going to go go now okay
on demand everywhere december 18th
you